i want to go back to the point you
brought up a moment ago about bread
and would any of this be happening if
people were starving
and i'll say this
feminism can only exist in a secured
society yes yes so uh and this is i was
reading evolutionary psychology and
evolutionary biology and like the rise
of gender roles
and gender roles break down when there
is no pressure on genders to pursue
these roles so in the in the early
humans were struggling to survive era
the women are the most important thing
every guy but one could die and the
society survives if the women die you
are in serious trouble so keeping the
women safe within the community was
important this eventually turns into
women just stay home and men go out and
work and do the dangerous jobs men go to
war women run you know the house and
stuff but once there's no more war once
there's no bears once there's no direct
threat
there's nothing there's there's no
danger so the women are not in danger to
leave and go out and start you know
being a part of society so this is not
me saying that gender roles are good or
are prescribing any moral um positive or
negative i'm saying this is literally
what the literature i was reading says
and so the issue then is today we're so
fat we're so happy we're so speak for
yourself well i mean i don't know
i mean
i'm not even happy
i mean look look
our borders used to be secure they're
not now our our country used to be
well-fed and this luxury these good
times made weak men which resulted in a
weak society and the things start
breaking right
so i think you know to your point if uh
if people were starving if there was a
conflict
maybe what we're starting to see
happening right now they're saying
there's gonna be a food shortage come
fall the harvest is gonna be really bad
they're telling farmers to stop farming
which is the craziest thing another
riding over it and shooting at farmers
right
people are going to be starving and
maybe it is like
some kind of
inevitability when a society gets woke
it goes broke and a broke society has no
food which then struggles and is forced
to get rid of the woman unless you're a
prepper and a traditional woman who
married a traditional man who's the man
of the house i am protected and i will
be fed and you will be
now we're good out here do you guys
think there will be an emperor an
america like that the republic will fall
on an empire will form some something is
always
always formed always but i want to say
you said morally you didn't want to talk
about like traditional relationships i
used to be one of those i'm a feminist i
want to wear the pants i was miserable i
was a miserable i can't say the word bad
words want to come out of my mouth i'm
trying people ladies
and now that i've like embraced my role
as a woman and i have a man who's a man
i feel dude i'm baking cakes and i'm
making pizza i love it and i'm
decorating stuff and i'm so happy and i
like being a chick and i i was more
unhappy trying to be a dude like i could
do anything a man can do no i can't i
can't even open a pickle jar different
things
oh great very different yes it's great
do you think women i've heard that women
have better pain tolerance though oh
yeah because we have to have babies so
regarding cooking you think women are
more drawn to being around hot tea
because it doesn't hurt them as much
that's uh oven bites and i can probably
deal with those better than men yeah
those are like almost third degree burns
but they're matching though yeah
thank you i can't be a handful anymore i
did end up with a much different view of
womanhood after uh
after i got pregnant and after my son
was born she was drastically different
um well for one thing
you guys have heard me say this before
like i'm very i'm very glad to be a mom
i'm very grateful every day that you
know i have my son and whatever um
but i just uh
it became a very different
it just became a very different view of
womanhood in terms of like prior to that
i was raised by feminists i was raised
by two feminists a stepmother and a mom
in different houses but they were both
very feminist and i had this idea that
you know you have to get your graduate
degree before you have kids and you have
to like pursue your career and all of
this kind of stuff and that's like the
stupid idea it turns out because i would
have way more kids now if i hadn't so
many of my friends way too happy you
know like i yeah i mean i had my son
when i was 35.
um
if i had started having kids before i
went to graduate school like graduate
school didn't make me happy i don't even
know if i learned anything you know like
i furthered the things i already knew
but i didn't need grad school i
certainly didn't need the debt i ended
up with and then they don't tell women
that 35 and above is geriatric
so rude no it's not even true
going you can have kids later and you
can endanger yourself and your children
so you could be selfish while you're
young and it's like our bodies are
designed to do that bounce back when
we're younger and as we get older you
know we get pre it gets harder and
harder so you watch someone start kids
in their twenties and then they're third
yeah and no lifestyle no like hedonistic
debauched lifestyle is worth those lies
no
no but i mean it's tough to tell someone
don't do what i did
like hey i partied hard in my 20s don't
do that
you be you don't get to enjoy the wild i
totally still could have partied hard in
my 20s which i did
uh and still had kids sooner be a
midwife
because yeah i did all kinds of crazy
stuff in my 20s and i don't regret it
but i could have started having kids
sooner this is uh one of the one of the
greatest things in terms of reducing
population tell women to be men tell
them to go work and be miserable but you
but but the idea is like
they say you can have it all you can
have a family and be the ceo and that's
just not true it's not even easy for a
dude to do all of these things very few
people are ceos
i should say a fortune 500 of big
successful companies right it is it is
hard to balance everything and what
we're seeing now is
for for for guys who are trying to have
families while they're while their wives
are working and they have kids even
they're struggling like which parent is
going to watch the kids oh the kids got
to go to a public school as daycare
basically so
when it was women were raising the kid
it was easier for the guy to succeed
when both are trying to succeed in the
exact same space neither there's an old
i think it's an old japanese saying a
person who tries to catch two rabbits
will catch neither something like that
that's basically what we're seeing so
look i it could be the dad who wants to
stay home find whatever it could be the
women who want to stay home with the
kids but someone needs to be in charge
of family yeah that's definitely true
and women are better at it i'm sorry and
that's why they i would try to erase us
now you know
you know why i think women are better at
it because women actually produce food
for their babies yeah so like could you
imagine if like the a mother gave birth
to like twins and then within a few
months like i'm going back to work it's
like just give the baby's formula i
guess it's like okay well you know
breastfeeding is an option what formula
there is none right now
so i'm not saying like i know certain
circumstances like um what what nurses
were a thing right i've never seen
anything for a very long time women have
the natural ability to feed their kids
not all of them but more more so than
men do therefore
there's advantages for women being in
charge of the family there's this
interesting thing that i was i was
actually talking to my son about
recently um there's surrogacy right
there's all of these things where he was
talking to me about how there's going to
be uh
uh pods there's going to be like pods
where children are gestated in pods and
i was like so this would be the
manufacturer of motherless children like
what do you think about that and we were
talking about it and i was like you know
i think it makes a lot of sense the way
that we have it now where a child is
connected to their mother as soon as
they're born because they've been
connected this whole time and being
pregnant gives you um
gives you sort of like a feeling of
protection of the child assuming
somebody's hormones yeah you know you
feel there is more of a connection and i
i think probably will end up in a place
where we have children gestated in you
know
sex robot style pods you know these
kinds of things i'm i'm sure that we're
heading in that direction um i hope i'm
dead by that
but i think that i think that we lose
our humanity and i think a lot of this
is an anti-humanist movement it's like
we hate ourselves
so much we hate everything that we came
from that we want to destroy it and we
want to destroy our connection to one
another what was alex jones saying that
they want the elites want to ascend like
they want to upload their consciousness
and like be immortal this is
transhumanism yeah i talked to zoltan
istvan about this a couple of years ago
and that's you know that's a i lost the
interview somewhere but um i know
instead of running it it's somewhere
literally somewhere i can't
mathematically calculate anything other
than transhumanist future because like
you look at the neanderthals and they
were vicious they would steal human
children and eat them when the when the
they would eat children yeah they would
they were like
so humans hunted them to extinction
essentially this is one theory uh
that i've been listening to lately but
like
we evolve and become semi-autonomous
robots that don't need to consume food
anymore humans are severe danger to our
species because they eat and destroy
their surroundings so we need to wipe
them out like that's that's i don't see
any other path first unless unless we
have total destruction right unless we
unless we have a total collapse of
society and then all of this stuff
disappears and we're strong survivors
yeah yeah assuming
there's an evolution right and then
we're in a situation where we don't have
pods because we don't even have the
resources to build these pods
like uh plastic surgery to retain youth
that didn't work everyone morphs into
the same face look at instagram and then
they they're trying with the fountain of
youth i think in sweden they're funding
all that research to try to extend life
that's not working so now what is the
upload elon musk i don't trust you
imagine imagine it this way yeah this is
what's happening right now whether
intentional or otherwise
imagine there's like a giant mountain
and the water is just rising every hour
by one foot the strongest people climb
to the top of the mountain with no
problem but most people can't even get
up the base and the water just floods up
the weaker people get engulfed by it get
wiped out and the stronger people
narrowly survive then the water recedes
everyone comes back down and goes about
their life what's happening now with the
reporting on ukraine and the famines and
the war and all that is that it's going
to be countries in in sub-saharan africa
it's going to be parts of turkey it's
going to be lebanon countries in the
middle east that will have no food
because they import their food from
ukraine and russia so outside the united
states it's going to be cataclysmic for
us
with the loss of access to their
resources to many of these countries
resources and the labor they produce for
us it'll get fairly bad
so there will be
it's it's
i guess you can call it whatever your
idea is there is a culling that is about
to occur i don't know if it's going to
be like mass death or anything like that
but they said during covet 250 million
people would starve due to the shutdown
of the economy something like that is is
going to happen
did that happen that didn't happen i
think i think mass derivation happened
during covet yeah i don't know i don't
know if they all died but i'm pretty
sure you know what that there was some
hungriness yeah right that was that's
what i look at
yeah a that's wild what's happening
see what you were just saying i feel
like that's how humanity always was we
were always culling out the weak and the
weirdos so we didn't have to deal with
this like first world coddling of
everyone where we're all surviving and i
hate saying it i don't want to see
anyone get hurt but maybe that's why
we're where we're at is science yeah
it's no longer the strongest now it's
the most adaptable well it's always
really been the most adaptable you just
used to need strength to adapt now you
need money and it's the rich kids that
are born into it that can afford a
helicopter to get up above the flood it
could be it could be that a natural
consequence just in evolution is that
wokeness and hive mind
like necrosis it emerges when a society
society becomes new gluttonous it may
just be an emergent phenomenon that
because everybody is well fed and what
what's this so i found some articles
about starvation and they're a little
unsettling so in haiti a bunch of
inmates starved to death but that could
be just a prison thing the u.n is saying
that 345 million people are marching to
the brink of starvation however much you
want to trust you but we saved grandma
who cares well yeah but we do not even
save grammar exactly we didn't allow
yeah and you're not even allowed to say
that anymore you're not allowed to say
that we should have protected the people
who needed protection the most because
that's there's a name for it it's like
some kind of theory that you're not
supposed to anyway lots of people are
headed towards starvation putin was
prepared to starve parts of the
developing world according to a yale
historian a month ago so i forgot what i
was talking about what's up coming up
starvation sorry
no that was before i started talking
about something okay sorry to me to
distract i was just reading about sri
lanka you got a room full of chicks dude
maybe not the first i want to make sure
it doesn't kill you yeah he's doing it
hell no we need someone on the inside oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait i don't remember i don't
remember what i remember oh emergent
phenomenon there we go what i was saying
is that
some people think it's a conspiracy that
powerful elites are like orchestrating
this this event or whatever whatever
they want to call it and the changing of
the world i think it's possible but it's
also possible that when a society has no
external threats
and the weak survive the weak way down
the society causing a collapse it's very
much at the fourth turning it's not
intentional it's possible it's
intentional but it could just be that
too many gluttonous weak people disrupt
the system and cause suffering which
results in a natural
sort of like
culling this the society gets weighed
down you know it's like a boat can carry
people but you put too much people on it
or someone gets too fat the boat sinks
yeah and then the people who are fit and
strong swim to safety and the people who
aren't don't make it although i feel bad
but you're right you're right yeah
that's true well this is how you're
always worked and we we take offense to
it because it kind of hurts our feelings
and i do think that a civilized society
should protect the weakest members like
old people and developmentally disabled
people but if you don't have that level
of sophistication anymore it goes very
much back to this primal
i need to survive survival of the
fittest and it's brutal like what
percent would you be willing to kneecap
your civilization to protect the weakest
two you know 78
that's kind of the point i'm making that
number changes so so look
we know that if deer are left unchecked
they destroy like the the ecosystem they
just eat like crazy so when there's deer
season it's like a certain amount of
deer and like the males are allowed to
be killed and things like that
we we know culling is important we know
about feral hogs people getting
helicopters and gun them down there's
too many they're destroying the
landscape and they'll they'll cause
serious problems they're not controlled
and a lot of this has to do with the
decimation of wolf populations in the in
the imbalance with with predators so we
have to fill that role
humans don't have natural predators
what so so what effectively puts
pressure on humans i think ultimately
there doesn't need to be any kind of
global leader who decides to kill people
to call civilization because weak people
eventually just
sink the ship
and then
the stronger people have to suffer
suffer because of it but then ultimately
it's just a natural phenomenon well if
this is the titanic since i'm a
traditionalist i'm going to need
children on the boats first see you
later dude
well
i think what's been happening is that
powerful elites in the u.s have watched
the ship hit the iceberg and are
stealing the the fine china
jumping up definitely seeing no stealing
the china you're right jumping on the
lifeboats and being like it's just a
routine test of the lifeboats don't
worry about it it's fine they're gone
the biden family is definitely like that
they've they've just got their they're
reaching out and stuff in their pockets
believe the people that defend him it's
kind of crazy right okay i loved bill
clinton i had a autographed book by him
and when i found out all the
crap about my daddy's from arkansas he's
from arkansas everything there is named
after bill clinton so that's what i was
grown up with yeah and i looked at that
book and i'm like disgusting and i threw
it away thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there